Public Sénat et écho DDS vous présente
pourvu que ça dure
[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure l'émission qui rend les
correspondances sur public Sénart avec
aujourd'hui cette question aurons-nous
les moyens de réussir notre transition
énergétique sachant qu'elle nécessite
des investissements publics
considérables si l'on veut des carboner
l'économie française et respecter le
trajectoire carbone compatible avec
l'accord de Paris pour en parler notre
invité invité spéciale Pierre Moscovici
premier président de la Cour des comptes
bonjour merci d'être là cette question
des moyens je la trouve très importante
et pour moi elle se pose cette question
des moyens pourquoi parce qu'on a une
dette publique française et vous le
savez qui est autour de 3 milliards
d'euros et des tôles intérêts qui ont
violemment qui sont violemment remontés
depuis un an on se dit que l'équation
financière l'équation budgétaire est
désormais beaucoup plus contrainte
complexes pour l'État et je vais dire
transition énergétique ou pas
oui mais il faut d'abord partir en effet
des grandes transitions qui sont devant
nous pour comprendre pourquoi il faut se
débrider ça y est des logiques trop
simple parfois en matière de finance
publique certains pensent que l'État
c'est mal et donc il faut couper la
dépense publique plutôt tout au
contraire pense que tout dépenses
publiques et bonne parce qu'il y a des
besoins sociaux il me semble que c'est
pas la bonne voie en réalité il y a des
bonnes dépenses publiques il y a des
dépenses publiques qui sont moins
efficaces trop coûteuses et qui auberent
j'ai cité du lendemain aujourd'hui nous
vivons une période de grande mutation on
a vécu la crise covid il y a la guerre
en Ukraine et il y a le retour de la
menace géostratégique et il y a
l'impératif profond du la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique de
limitation des émissions de CO2 de la
sobriété énergétique et tout ça ça crée
des besoins considérables il y a des
besoins pour notre système éducatif pour
notre défense nationale des besoins pour
encore une fois la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique pour
c'est pas légitime c'est indispensable
c'est nécessaire et ça représente des
montants d'investissement absolument
considérables qu'il faut financer or
quand vous avez une dette publique trop
élevée c'est fameux 3000 milliards
d'euros mais c'est pas que ça quand vous
remboursez annuellement à peu près 50
milliards d'euros que c'est le deuxième
budget de l'État dansait déjà derrière
l'éducation nationale
en passant oui ça devrait être à 70
milliards d'euros d'après le programme
de stabilité de la France et donc
c'est plus anodin on est sorti de la
place des taux d'intérêt négatif ou
formidable un effet d'aubaine
extraordinaire vous en étiez vous payez
moins c'est fini tout ça et donc si on
veut pouvoir financer de l'avenir
financer l'investissement il faut se
désendetter maintenant pour trouver des
marges de manœuvre et des moyens et
c'est pour ça que quand je réfléchis à
cette question je ne les fais pas dans
une logique d'austérité je ne le fais
pas dans une logique au contraire des
portes mais pour se donner les moyens et
pour faire de la dépense publique mais
intelligente vous savez aujourd'hui il y
a deux monticules qui seront face à face
il y a un une montagne d'investissement
et un mur de dette et tant que le mur de
dette croix la montagne d'investissement
elle ne peut pas monter vous savez quand
on se retrouve
mais quand on interroge les Français
voilà sondage de la date un petit peu il
date de novembre dernier de l'Ifop la
réduction la dette publique quand on
interroge les Français ça arrive dans
les derniers en dernier position des
priorités économiques en gros tout le
monde rencontre fiche un peu de cette
histoire de dette comment on l'explique
cette forme d'indifférence de la part de
l'opinion sur cette question est-ce que
c'est le résultat un petit peu aussi
quand même du quoi qu'il en coûte où on
a dépensé je regardais les chiffres on a
injecté quasiment depuis 2020 300
milliards d'argent public dans
l'économie donc les gens se disent que
finalement on peut continuer
tranquillement sur cette trajectoire là
est-ce que c'est responsable il y a deux
choses que les Français mesurent ils
mesurent d'abord que la déportivité
n'est pas toujours de qualité
dépenser beaucoup pourquoi pas mais
condition d'avoir des services publics
de qualité si les Français
que l'éducation nationale était en
pleine forme et que l'hôpital pétait la
forme à la fin il serait ravi ils ne
sont pas donc ils ont une exigence par
rapport à leur argent ils se disent
c'est moi qui paye comme concile
tribuable ou à l'argent ça c'est la
première des choses et puis la deuxième
chose c'est qu'ils sont aussi conscients
que le niveau des prélèvements
obligatoires des impôts est élevé dans
notre pays et si vous prenez le
croisement des deux si vous vous dites
au fond il faut une qualité de la
dépense publique qui soit meilleure et
tes impôts qui soient raisonnables à ce
moment-là vous aboutissez à la réduction
du déficit et de la dette et c'est en ce
cycle la dette qui est sans doute un
sujet plus théorique
découle quand même dans notre
préoccupation des Français par ailleurs
les Français sont attachés à l'euro et
je crois qu'ils sont assez conscients
qu'un pays qui décroche en matière de
finances publiques un pays qui est peu
crédible est un pays qui prend du retard
dans la zone euro nous n'avons pas
vocation à prendre du retard nous devons
être leader en la matière et je préfère
que nous soyons leader par l'exemple que
nous montrons plutôt que par la force de
notre endettement à la réalité c'est que
cette remontée des taux d'intérêt change
l'équation financière et là on est pas
dans le sujet de notre transition
écologique
assurément parce que précisément
on aurait dû investir avant à l'époque
où les taux d'intérêt était à zéro dans
la transition écologique il faut pas
avoir trop de nostalgie et on a quand
même investi dans la transition
écologique nous jetons pas la pierre
nous ont flagions pas c'est pas ça que
je veux dire du tout parce que le
chiffre significatif pour moi c'est
celui de la charge de la dette et vous
avez raison ce qui change
fondamentalement c'est le contexte de
financement quand nous avions du taux
d'intérêt négatif on avait cette espèce
situation magique où la charte de la
tête est très faible c'était en 2021 26
milliards d'euros c'est monté maintenant
à 41 ce sera les prochaines à 49 c'est
vrai à 71 et ça veut dire que c'est une
dépense publique plutôt un poste de
dépenses publiques qui augmente de 8
milliards d'euros par an lequel augmente
de cette façon là mais c'est 8 milliards
d'euros de plus par an pour la charge de
la dette ces 8 milliards d'euros en
moins exactement l'écologie pour la
transition écologique la transition
numérique l'éducation et c'est pour ça
que le désendettement doit être fait pas
par amour de l'austérité moi je suis pas
pour la politique strogneux simplement
pour pouvoir financer les bonnes
dépenses pour retrouver les marges pour
le faire après ici certains vous diront
pourquoi pas accepter davantage
d'endettement public pour réussir cette
transition énergétique pourquoi pas
alourdir notre dette pour décarboner les
communistes françaises on va créer des
emplois ça fera rentrer des cotisations
sociales c'est un discours qu'on peut
entendre ou pas ça
oui et non il y a une bonne dette il y a
une mauvaise dette la bonne dette c'est
celle qui en effet finance des
Investissements d'Avenir rentable
peut-être le cas oui bien sûr et donc je
ne préconise pas qu'on arrête totalement
de s'endetter je préconise qu'on réduise
notre endettement et qu'on chasse la
mauvaise dette celle qui finance des
dépenses ordinaires de fonctionnement
celles qui finance des dépenses
inefficaces mais au total c'est mon
point de vue là de président de la Cour
des comptes le président du Conseil des
finances publiques nous avons un niveau
d'endettement qui est certes soutenable
encore aujourd'hui non pas de problème
pour financer notre dette mais nous
avons quand même un début de
préoccupation sur notre crédibilité il
est là si la France devient un mauvais
élève dans la zone euro ça se voit si ça
se voit ça se paye j'ajoute de plus que
au total si le niveau de la dette est
trop élevé si la charge doit être élevée
alors la marge de manœuvre pour financer
les veste marketing baissent donc plus
nous enretterons plus une charge de la
dette moins nous pourrons financer les
bonnes dépenses voilà pour la raison
pour laquelle il faut se désendetter
intelligemment en travaillant sur la
qualité de la dépense publique c'est la
raison pour laquelle ce que je préconise
c'est pas une politique de rabot
budgétaire surtout pas sur les questions
de transition écologique puisque je dis
au contraire qu'il faut plus
d'investissement ce que je préconise
c'est une revue de dépenses publiques
qui procède de manière complètement
différente c'est une véritable on a
souvent été revue dépensé les
conférences on appelle les spécialistes
on n'a jamais eu
jamais il y a eu des exercices qui ont
été faits
la map disons-le pardon pour les
acronymes
pour l'essentiel des politiques
budgétaires dissimulées c'est-à-dire on
dit comment est-ce qu'on fait les
économies une revue dépense publique
comme le font nos partenaires européens
j'ai été commissaire européen pendant
quelques années j'ai pu voir ça chez les
autres c'est autre chose c'est on prend
une politique publique prenez la
politique d'éducation prenez la
politique du logement prenez la
politique
santé prenez les dépenses fiscales on se
demande comment fonctionne cette
politique publique est-ce que d'abord
est efficace sur la question de ce que
c'est la question qu'on se pose
aujourd'hui avec vous sur est-ce qu'on
aura au pas les moyens de réussir cette
transition énergétique elle implique des
investissements majeurs publics et
privés les deux évidemment est-ce qu'on
sait combien d'argent public il faudra
mobiliser pour respecter l'accord de
Paris Bruno Le Maire mise de l'économie
nous dit 60 à 70 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires par an pour réussir
encore une fois cette transition
énergétique mais c'est pas que de
l'argent public et ça paraît énorme en
plus
trois points de vie le musée finance à
une idée assez précise de ce que sont
les besoins effectivement après il y a
la question du reste à charge qui
finance et c'est
une charge plutôt c'est un
investissement qui doit être répartie
sur l'ensemble de la société mais
incontestablement les acteurs publics la
puissance publique ont un rôle majeur à
jouer en la matière et nous devons
dégager des capacités
franchement si c'est 50 à 70 milliards
d'euros je préfère qu'on dépense 50 à 70
milliards d'euros pour la transition
écologique plutôt que 70 milliards
d'euros pour rembourser une dette dont
chaque euro ne sert à rien pour le
citoyen et en même temps dans ce budget
2023 on a 45 milliards qui sont alloués
au bouclier tarifaires sur l'énergie le
gaz l'électricité et là je me dis ça
pose quand même des questions en matière
écologique parce que les boucliers de
chaque énergie c'est c'est bien ça
nécessaire pour pour aider les Français
alléger la facture mais c'est pas ça qui
va nous inciter à nous désintoxiquer des
énergies fossiles pendant il faut dire
les choses quoi je crois au total que
cette période d'inflation forte il faut
être capable de d'agir pour lutter
contre l'inflation mais il faut le faire
de manière un ciblée de temporaire et
ces dispositifs continuent de coûter
extrêmement cher vous savez peut-être
que en 2023 il y a encore quelques douze
5 milliards d'euros consacrés aux suites
des mesures covid c'est considérable et
37 milliards consacrés aux mesures
énergie ça fait un total de 50 dans les
dépenses publiques pour 2023 c'est pas
rien après c'est vrai que on a tous
envie de rénover
énergétiquement thermiquement j'ai envie
d'un au bâtiments on a tous envie de
rouler avec une voiture électrique ou
avoir une pompe à chaleur chez soi mais
ça coûte très cher et le reste a charge
pour les Français aujourd'hui très trop
important et ce qu'il faut aller plus
loin justement que les mesures de
soutien actuel et d'aide français pour
justement embarquer tout le monde parce
que sur le papier on a tous envie de le
faire mais après on attend les moyens
c'est là où il y a du ciblage à faire
tout de même ça peut pas être tout pour
tout le monde on peut pas à la fois veut
dire comme je le fais réduisons notre
endettement ayant une approche
intelligente de la dépense publique et
puis ouvrons le chéquier en France en
cible mal possible mal mais surtout il
faut vous évoquer de dépenses qui elles
sont nécessaires en effet pour la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments on le
sait il est nécessaire d'y avoir une
forme d'aide publique pour ce qui est
des véhicules électriques sans doute est
nécessaire mais il faut aussi
la déportivité nécessaire en
l'occurrence c'est c'est de faire en
sorte qu'il y a un équipement suffisant
en batterie et un plan qui est mise en
oeuvre de ce point de vue là ou qui
était décidé il y a quelques semaines je
crois un milliard d'euros par an ça va
dans la bonne direction parce qu'il faut
que nous soyons à la hauteur mais il
faut aussi inciter les constructeurs à
produire tout simplement des véhicules
électriques qui soient adaptés à la
classe moyenne à chacun et pas seulement
des SUV c'est trop le cas aujourd'hui
donc là on voit bien que il y a d'une
part les Américains ont un joli mot pour
ça il dit c'est
une incitation à agir au fond la
puissance publique allume la mèche en
quelque sorte mais derrière il faut que
les forces soient partagées partagées
avec les entreprises et aussi avec les
ménages tout de même le dispositif
d'aide à la rénovation thermique m'a
prime rénove aujourd'hui c'est un
financement de 2,5 milliards d'euros par
an dans une autre émission qu'on a faite
on a eu le patron de saint-gobains qui
nous a dit sur vraiment il faut mettre
quatre fois plus si on veut en finir
avec les passoires thermiques en France
on dit là aussi une question de moyens
alors il se trouve que la Cour des
comptes a fait un rapport sur ma prime
rénov c'était ce qu'on appelle chez mon
audit flash pour faire un peu plus
rapidement que les autres c'était je
croyais un an et demi qui montrait que
le dispositif a été mis en place de
toute façon assez assez efficace et
rapide plutôt un bon dispositif
quand même quelques,5 milliards d'euros
mais il n'était pas démontré que
l'efficience de chaque euro mise en
oeuvre par la plus belle offre c'est
suffisante en termes justement de
résultats
et de surcroît le problème de rénovation
technique
c'est que primal off ça s'adresse à des
propriétaires alors que beaucoup nos
concitoyens sont locataires et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut aussi inciter les
propriétaires pardonnez-moi procéder de
ce point de vue là j'ai tendance à
penser que l'effort à faire le décision
à prendre serait davantage naturel
réglementaire comment faire en sorte de
contraindre ou d'inciter les
propriétaires à rénover thermiquement
les logements dont ils une propriétaire
plutôt que de donner de l'argent public
pour financer ça enfin tout ne peut pas
être fait par de l'argent public dans ce
pays 58% de dépenses publiques dans le
pub c'est considérable le président de
Giscard d'Estaing dans les années 40%
dans les années 70 disait nous serons
socialistes la France le jour où la
France aurait 40 % de dépenses publiques
dans le pays que sommes-nous aujourd'hui
et c'est un ancien socialiste qui vous
le dit les il y a aussi ses dépenses
quand on regarde il y a la dépense
globale et puis elle dépense qui sont
néfastes pour le climat et
l'environnement ça pèse dans le budget
2023 on a fait des comptes 67 milliards
d'euros entre eux et boucliers
tarifaires les niches fiscal sur la taxe
de consommation sur les produits
énergétiques le taux rébus TVA pour les
produits énergétiques et ce qu'il faut
pas aussi la faire un peu le ménage pour
réduire notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles et en même temps pour réduire
ses dépenses fiscales brunes et pour
verdir tout ça même si c'est un sujet
qui est explosif parce que ça touche le
profession comme balancer comme les
transports routiers les taxis les
pêcheurs c'est compliqué pour eux et je
pense que le chiffrage peut être
amélioré c'est ce qu'on appelle la
cotation il y a maintenant des documents
budgétaires qui sont des vers qui disent
un peu ce que sont les dépenses
publiques qui sont fléchés comme
favorables ou défavorables à
l'environnement ou à la transition
énergétique ou climatiques il faut
vérifier il faut vérifier
c'est qu'il y a à peu près 169 milliards
d'euros dépenses publiques il y en a un
dixième qui sont coté 37 milliards
favorables et quelques-19 milliards
comme défavorable donc la balance est
plutôt dans le sens défavorable il y a
19,6 milliards de dépenses dites brunes
et sur celle-là il faut travailler y
compris sur les dépenses fiscales qui
représentent 7 milliards d'euros
c'est-à-dire des moindres recettes et
donc la Cour des comptes fera un travail
aussi sur ces dépenses fiscales hostiles
ou défavorables à l'environnement mais
ce que je crois c'est qu'il faut élever
le niveau de cotation il faut qu'il y
ait plus de dépenses publiques qui
soient coté comme soit de favorable sur
les favorable peu importe le résultat et
il faut que toute la logique de notre
raisonnement budgétaire toute la logique
de nos finances publiques soit tournée
vers cet objectif qu'un objectif de la
société tout entière vous savez que la
Cour des comptes va y participer je l'ai
dit à travers nos notes thématiques mais
aussi leur apport public annuel de la
Cour des comptes ce fameux document que
nous préférons chaque année l'année
prochaine sera intégralement consacré
aux politiques publiques d'adaptation au
changement climatiques après on a
compris que l'idée maîtresse il est
sous-jacente à Moscovici c'est de
retrouver des marges de manœuvre pour
financer cette transition énergétique
après encore une fois ça se passe ça
passera pas par plus d'impôts puisqu'on
a dit qu'on avait des prélèvements
obligatoires qui sont permis déjà les
plus élevés d'Europe voire du monde ça
veut dire moins dépenses publiques mais
lesquelles et en même temps on a vu que
le gouvernement demandait récemment 5%
d'économie à tous les ministères pour
dégager en tout 7 milliards d'euros
l'année prochaine pour financer
justement les investissements on a plein
de sujet dans la transition écologique
ça c'est de la bonne gestion pour vous
coûter la gestion par le gouvernement
c'est la gestion budgétaire et s'il
s'agit en effet de faire des économies
sur façon de postes pour financer des
dépenses publiques
écologiques c'est vertueux ça va dans la
bonne direction ma logique et un tout
petit peu différente je ne suis plus
aujourd'hui au gouvernement ou dans un
exécutif comme je l'étais à la
commission également je suis dans une
instance qui réfléchit et qui travaille
sur la qualité de la dépense publique je
crois qu'il faut changer de paradigme
j'ai changé de paradigme c'est se
demander encore une fois comment
fonctionne les politiques publiques
plutôt que de se dire je vais couper 5%
tout le temps sur tout le monde ici il
faut couper plus là il faut dépenser
plus il faut les regarder ce qui marche
et ce qui ne marche pas il faut aller
soulever le capot des politiques
publiques se demander si notre dépense
pour le logement justement qui est très
importante elle est efficace nous
demandait si la réponse elle est non la
réponse on peut vite répondre nous
allons le faire de manière étayée je
suis diplomate en la matière mais je
pense sincèrement que voilà un poste sur
lequel on peut dépenser mieux et ne pas
dépenser plus que nos voisins deux fois
plus de l'Union européenne en la matière
avec des résultats pas forcément les
meilleurs ni au terme de construction ni
en termes de logements social ni en
termes de qualité thermique des
bâtiments mais c'est ce qu'il faut faire
et pardon de le répéter la revue de
dépenses publiques ça sert à ça c'est
précisément de ça dont il s'agit
vraiment j'appelle tout le monde a y
participer et j'appelle une vraie
mobilisation sur ce sujet là parce que
c'est ça qui permettra de faire des
réformes dans ce pays c'est pas d'être
brutal c'est de se dire à partir de
l'analyse d'une qualité de dépenses
publiques ou d'une politique publique
comme parce qu'on la réforme pour le
meilleur elle peut être plus efficace
elle peut être plus juste elle peut être
plus réduire les dépenses publiques en
matière de logement et avoir de
meilleurs résultats
je veux pas
quand j'ai déjà je me suis exprimé sur
le sujet ça a provoqué des réactions
dans le secteur alors que je n'ai rien
dit de définitif il suffit pas il s'agit
pas de condamner la dépense publique il
s'agit de la rendre plus efficace moi je
ne plaide pas du tout pour qu'on fasse
moins je plaide pour qu'on fasse mieux
et je crois que oui c'est possible dans
secteur que dans beaucoup d'autres et
nous allons présenter 9 notes
thématiques
à part le logement il y a l'éducation il
y a
la santé orbitale il y a aussi des
pensées antiques à la sécurité
intérieure je vais les présenter bientôt
bon après
il y a les dépenses fiscales
parce que ça c'est un sujet tout à fait
massif il y a quelques 170 milliards de
dépenses fiscale alors toutes ne sont
pas néfastes mais certaines peuvent
l'être et je vais citer à nouveau ce que
j'évoquais quelque chose et quelques 7
milliards d'euros de dépenses fiscales
qui sont déjà estimés dans les documents
budgétaires
déposés par le gouvernement comme étant
tes dépenses défavorables à la
transition énergétique sur les aides aux
entreprises c'est 150 milliards d'euros
ce sera aussi dans le champ de nos notes
on se dit pas trop près les choses
évidemment mais quand même pour les
conditionner on pourrait voilà les
revoir pour voir si justement se
redonner en ayant cette logique de se
redonner des marges de manœuvre
budgétaire pour financer cette
transition énergétique je passe au thé
aux conclusions c'est notre sont en
train d'être faites je les présenterai
fin juin début juillet mais il y aura
avec les notes non seulement des
analyses mais des préconisations des
propositions précises et si on doit par
exemple proposer de conditionner les
aides il faut dire lesquelles et comment
mais il y aura aussi une autre
thématique consacrée aux anneaux
d'entreprises oui c'est un gisement
manifeste quand même de réflexion et
peut-être d'économie mais d'économie
encore une fois pas pour les économies
moi je suis pas pour raboter je suis pas
pour limiter la dépense publique je
pense que nous avons besoin d'État dans
cette période que les changements
majeurs
des temps qui viennent nous appellent à
un État fort un état qui investit un
état efficace un état présent mais à
présent n'est pas un état endetté et pas
un état trop gros n'est pas un état
inefficace il n'est pas un état qui est
à côté des priorités de l'avenir sur le
site juste sur le signal prix est-ce que
ce pourrait être une solution que de
taxer plus qui pollue
ça c'est ça
automobile d'accès plus les carburants
sachant que le sujet est inflammable
puisqu'il est à l'origine de cette crise
des gilets jaunes donc
c'est un sujet sur lequel il faut
toujours travailler prudence vous savez
d'ailleurs comme de manière générale sur
la fiscalité écologique je m'y suis
attaché quand j'étais commissaire
européen je n'ai pas réussi en la
matière et c'est toujours très difficile
je crois que en tout cas une chose qui
est très importante par rapport à la
crise des gilets jaunes
si tu réflexion qu'on doit avoir c'est
que si on fait des taxes écologiques et
elles peuvent être nécessaires à tel ou
tel moment il faut toujours penser à un
accompagnement social pour ceux qui sont
le plus impactés qu'on utilise des
difficultés de leur vie concrète j'ai
été pendant 20 ans député à Montbéliard
dans une vie antérieure j'ai pas été
totalement surpris par le mouvement des
gilets jaunes parce que je sais que
l'ouvrier de
Seloncourt ou bétoncourt des communes de
ma circonscription ou d'à côté qui
allaient travailler à l'usine de Sochaux
en prenant sa voiture diesel le matin
pour fabriquer des voitures au diesel
quand on lui disait tu vas rouler
maintenant à 80 km/h et tu vas payer
plus cher sur le diesel ça passe pas et
si on lui explique en plus qu'il faut
être mobile alors que son patrimoine
immobilier a baissé parce qu'il y avait
des industrialisations c'est comme ça
qu'on crée des foyers de tension et donc
il risque de rejeter le social David
Jacquot il faut les penser ensemble et
pas l'un contre l'autre et chaque fois
qu'on pense fiscalité écologique ce
serait peut-être une bonne direction et
je pense qu'il y a une direction
nécessaire pour l'avenir se demander
comment est-ce qu'on compense pour ceux
qui sont les algurements impactés pour
qu'il y ait acceptation acceptabilité
sociale de cette transition écologique
qui peut être rejetée parce que ça coûte
trop cher ça coûte 30 % plus il faut que
l'écologie devienne une cause pour tous
il faut que la transition écologique
devienne une cause pour tous ça doit pas
être un phénomène générationnel ou un
phénomène social c'est le fait quelque
chose qui est réservé aux plus jeunes ou
plus riches si c'est comme ça on va
créer des fractures dans la société et
ça doit être au contraire quelque chose
dans lequel chacun s'investit où on sent
qu'il y a des bénéfices pour chacun on
parle de la rénovation thermique alors
ça pour le coup c'est quelque chose qui
concerne beaucoup les classes populaires
ou les classes moyennes dans notre pays
sur les véhicules électriques il faut
effectivement donner des aides à ceux
qui ont besoin il faut aussi faire en
sorte que les constructeurs
ils me répètent mais construisent des
véhicules qui soient accessibles pour
tous évidemment en France également
construit en France évidemment aussi
d'ailleurs ce qui est en passant
vous doutez que j'ai été assez attaché à
l'automobile française pour le rester
sur les justement on parlait de Sochaux
des collectivités locales c'est
intéressant est-ce que elle aussi elle
doivent financer davantage la transition
climatique parce qu'on parle de l'État
mais aussi les collectivalités et
certains diront peut-être un peu moins
de rond-point et les dépenses comme les
restes à charge fatalement partagées
surtout l'idée
que l'État peut tout et que l'État
d'ouatou que tout est dépenses publiques
que 12 doit s'appuyer sur l'état ça
n'est pas le cas ça ne sera pas le cas
ça ne doit pas être le cas donc il
faudra partage où l'État prend toute sa
part mais où les autres prises les
connectiques car les mêmes les
particuliers et prennent leur part bien
sûr c'est pas c'est pas les tas qui se
substitue à tous les acteurs de la
société pour conclure ici au-delà des
moyens publics qu'on a largement évoqué
et ce qu'il faut aussi en parallèle une
espèce de planification de cette
transition énergétique avec des
objectifs précis atteindre de taux
d'équipement pompe à chaleur en véhicule
électrique n'importe quoi voilà une
vraie planification oui je crois que
c'est absolument indispensable je vais
prendre un exemple
on sait que il faut qu'on change notre
vie électrique donc il y en a côté un
plan sur le nucléaire il y a aussi un
plan de construction d'éoliennes
en mer et on a envisagé qu'il y en a 40
ou 50 c'était en 2011 nous sommes jours
après je crois qu'il y en a une qui
opérationnelle qui est à Saint-Nazaire
et ça prouve bien que il suffit pas de
mettre en place des intentions des
maîtres des ambitions de produire des
discours mais qu'il faut d'ailleurs que
les actes suivent et ce que je mets en
cause c'est pas d'ailleurs la nature des
ambitions la sincérité des discours
c'est simplement que il faut à chaque
fois dire quels sont les objectifs et
comment on fait et oui la planification
écologique est indispensable et ce point
de vue là la création d'un d'un scrutage
général la planification écologique qui
doit être doté des moyens nécessaires et
surtout qui doit être accompagné d'une
volonté politique constante est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle et donc oui je crois
qu'il faut s'engager dans cette
planification écologique qui doit être
comme la planification le fut vous savez
au lendemain de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale l'affaire de tous la
planification c'était une mise en
mouvement de la société c'était aussi un
dialogue social constant la
planification c'est pas uniquement des
chiffres réservés et qui viennent de
là-haut celui quelque chose qui fait
dialoguer le haut et le bas les Français
avec leur état et c'est ce à quoi je
restais très attaché allez merci pour
cet entretien Pierre Moscovici premier
président de la cour des commerciaux
merci à vous voilà c'est la fin de
pourvu que ça dure l'émission qui rend
les correspondables et missions à voir
ou revoir sur Public Sénat et en replay
sur notre nouvelle plateforme public
sénat.fr on se retrouve dans deux
semaines
[Musique]
c'était pourvu que ça dure avec le
soutien déco des déesses